prix d'interprétation à cannes c'est un
acteur un comédien ne peut pas rêver
plus belle récompense
monsieur jamais jamais incarne ici se
vend 20 ans et je sais c'est vrai
j'avais un tout le pays d aller vers
année avec un calme fait un beau cadeau
[Musique]
un groupe aussi
elle s'appelle le était en compte pour
jamais dit que nous fassions pour votre
part au concert sur toi selon bruxelles
surtout par sa capuche est bon pour moi
je me tourne tout soit fait théâtre un
cinéma dans les films l'amitié la
solidarité avec ses copains c'est l'avis
de pascal duquesne dans ce groupe ils se
connaissent depuis 20 ans il travaille
là sur un spectacle qui parle de leurs
difficultés de vivre au matin je
côtoyais un des copains que j'ai avec
moi fait remballer certes il ya des gens
impliqués qui viennent pour me voir
nouveau certaines tout le monde rigole à
la plus chouette on continue comme ça et
deux ans et demi après cannes toujours
les autres
le groupe star je pars tarn ont remonté
seul parfois il ait jamais connu ni
jamais connu c'est ici au crayon de
bruxelles le centre de rééducation et
d'éducation artistique pour handicapés
mentaux que pascal duquenne a travaillé
le théâtre et l'expression corporelle
avec d'autres jeunes notre activité est
différent pour moi
enfin le théâtre des faits
il cherchait position moi j'ai fait
parfois on prend leur soif leur entrevue
aussi on l'avait fait noir blanc pas
facile à faire moi je pense que nous
sommes handicapés pas voulu dire à sa
copine kim jong il joué dans les films
comme moi avec moi dans le film est
vraiment brunel mano j'étais mécontent
et j'ai lu vie elle hébergeait un ami
cher à la bêta uccle et moi il est ici à
part toi pour faire de chantant qui est
six yeux bien et qui viennent ici pour
le maire ici c'est plus être est encore
très longtemps